dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana Aoife here in
this piece of work we are interested in
simulating the dynamics of water waves
there are quite a few forces acting on a
bucket of water such as surface tension
internal pressure external force fields
such as wind for instance and gravity
therefore it is not a surprise that
these waves can become quite complex
with a lot of high frequency details
that are difficult to simulate
accurately modeling wave reflections
after colliding with solids is also an
important and highly sought after detail
to capture this piece of work simulates
Sir George Biddle Ares dispersion model
now what does this mean exactly the area
model describes many common wave
phenomena accurately such as how longer
waves are dominated by gravitational
forces and have shorter waves dance
mostly according to the will of surface
tension
however as amazing this theory is it
does not formulate these quantities in a
way that would be directly applicable to
a computer simulation the main
contribution of this paper is a new
convolution formulation of this model in
some more optimizations that can be
directly added into a simulation and not
only that but the resulting algorithm
paralyzes and Maps well to the graphical
card in our computers we have earlier
discussed what a convolution is
essentially it is a mathematical
operation that can add reverberation to
the sound of our guitar or accurately
simulate how light bounces around under
our skin links to these episodes are
available in the video description and
at the end of the video check them out
I'm sure you'll have a lot of fun with
them regarding applications as the
technique obeys aries classical
dispersion model i expect and hope this
to be useful for ocean and coastal
engineering and assimilating huge tidal
waves
note that limitations apply for instance
the original linear theory is mostly
good for shallow water simulations and
larger waves in deeper waters the
proposed approximation itself also has
inherent limitations such as the
possibility of waves going through
thinner objects the resulting algorithm
is however very accurate
honestly a joy to watch it is also shown
to support larger scale scenes here you
see how beautifully it can simulate the
capillary waves produced by these
raindrops and of course the waves around
the Swans in the pond this example took
roughly one-and-a-half second per frame
to compute you know the drill a couple
more follow-up papers down the line and
it will surely run in real time can't
wait
also please let me know in the comment
section whether you have found this
episode understandable was it easy to
follow too much your feedback is as
always highly appreciated thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time